tendresse c'est si rare dans un journal
mais c'est le jour ou jamais saint
valentin nous le permet le patron des
amoureux nous demande de le suivre dans
la bourgade mill road depuis des siècles
roquemaure d'avignon patrice romdhane et
jean françois georges et ti n'ont pas
résisté à la tentation
sigi saint-valentin version musée grévin
ce visage de cire le pull de zélés de
l'homme l'a imaginée au fil du temps ils
reposent près de ces reliques supposé
contenu dans une boîte de fer blanc
qu'il est hors de question d'ouvrir on
ne sait jamais si elle était vide
car enfin temps de village assure
posséder la dépouille du martyr mais
lequel peux le jurer vous réparé jurés
ça irait très bien
brad que juré mais il est certainement
dit reliques d'un saint valentin puis
s'il y avait dix sept chrétiens
martyrisés il s'appelait valentin et
celle ci sans celle d'un prêtre romain
qui a été exécuté de 14 février au land
de sarre
un délice elle sent arriver ici en 1823
1863 le phylloxéra ronge la vigne par la
simple présence de ces reliques dépêché
en urgence de rome saint valentin
recouche le mal depuis les gosiers
roquemaurois voue une reconnaissance
éternelle aux faiseurs de miracles
l'événement se vit en marge du cortège
officiel qui une fois l'an arrache les
costumes d'époque à l'affection la
naphtaline alors de partout à courre les
amoureux
nous sommes amoureux extrêmement
tabacalera nous sommes amoureux l'on
pense au passé il ya 44 ans on est
mariés
ça représente quand même quelque chose
d'un peu fabuleux pascal ça va hein t'as
quoi faire des trucs en plus roquemaure
exploite son filon l'amour n'oublions
pas que la saint-valentin création du
lobby des fleuristes obéit à des
considérations mercantiles et cela ici
chacun l'a bien saisi les français ont
le sens de la fête c'est connu les
anglais celui des contrastes ils ont
célébré la saint valentin d'une manière
inédite
côté cour le prince charles côté ville
le chômage valérie fournier un billet
doux un mot d'amour destiné au premier
ministre john major
les députés travaillistes anglais n'ont
rien perdu de leur humour à l'occasion
de la saint valentin
malgré la crise qui frappe leur pays
trois millions de personnes
voudrais tu aimais un travail comprenait
trois millions de chômeurs le niveau du
chômage est intolérable cela appauvrit
les gens qui n'ont pas de travail
brisent leurs familles et jette les
jeunes dans la rue en fait le pays dans
le plus incroyable d ordre économique
les réalités économiques de son pays
semblait bien loin des pensées du pôle
charles hier en virginie mais il fera
également preuve d'humour devant des
étudiants les professeurs de son
ancienne université
à cette époque j'étais jeune et
relativement inexpérimenté l'amour et
ses méandres
il ne connaissait pas encore lady di non
plus d'ailleurs
comme la plupart d'entre vous ici
décidément dans l'adversité les anglais
semblent être prêts à toutes les
facéties le chars français leclerc a
battu le chars américains abrams et le
char britannique challenger tout dans la
bataille économique qui les opposait
dans le golfe persique les émirats
arabes unis l'ont préféré à ses
concurrents occidentaux ils ont trouvé
plus performants et comme les émirats
ont beaucoup d'argent ils en achètent
d'un coup d'un seul 436 nicolas winckler
pierre joxe a aujourd'hui d'excellentes
raisons pour sourire c'est un contrat en
or qu'il a décrochée à abou dhabi
où se tenait ce week end le plus
important salon d'armement au
moyen-orient la partie était pourtant
loin d'être gagnée il ya quelques
semaines la france devait en effet faire
face à deux importants concurrents
les anglais et les amériques ce matin le
ministre de la défense des émirats
tranché enfin les émirats arabes unis
ont décidé de se porter acquéreur pour
leurs forces armées de 436 chars leclerc
fabriqués en france par le giat 436
chars leclerc cela représente pas moins
de trois milliards et demi de dollars
près de 20 milliards de nos francs
un succès donc pour les constructeurs
français de giat industries une nouvelle
qui rassure les employés des usines de
tarbes et de roanne
le char leclerc que vous voyez ici c'est
un monstre de 53 tonnes capable de
rouler à plus de 70 km heure
bourré d'électronique il peut tirer en
marche de jour comme de nuit
son canon de 120 mm peut viser et
atteindre avec une extrême précision si
cible en une seule minute
c'est donc une arme de guerre
redoutablement meurtrière que les
français s'apprêtent à livrer dès la fin
de l'année 1994
et puisque les bons comptes font les
bons amis les émirats ont exigé de la
france qu'elle réinvestit 60% du montant
du contrat
dans des projets de développement
économique un sacrifice très librement
consentis par la france qui espère bien
supplanter ainsi définitivement ses
concurrents anglais et américains un
dimanche riche en petites phrases
politiques campagne électorale aubry
oblige notre sélection du jour un
conseil acide de jacques barrot le
modéré à françois mitterrand est une
critique acerbe de pierre bérégovoy à
l'intention de l'opposition écoutons
d'abord le président du groupe centriste
à l'assemblée invité aujourd'hui de
l'heure de vérité
ce que je souhaite c'est que le
président de la république lui-même
respectant l'esprit de la constitution
se pose la question de savoir s'il doit
renoncer s'il doit re re consulter les
français d'une manière ou d'une autre
en tout cas il ne peut pas ne pas
prendre acte d'une très forte volonté
nouvelle du pays
parce que c'est ça la vème république
c'est que le président puis
son pouvoir son autorité sa légitimité
du peuple et que si ce peuple change
d'avis le président république ne peut
pas ne pas qu'il y ait une élection
présidentielle finalement la fin du mois
de mars on se préférable pour la france
c'est ce et suivons maintenant à nevers
avec jean yves perrin pierre bérégovoy
qui accuse la droite de vouloir raser
gratis
ce qui nous en crochet en 81 et 82
certaine prudence économie et en
particulier les dévaluations qui était
la conséquence de l'écart d'inflation
entre la france et l'allemagne
aujourd'hui sont prêts à faire bien pire
que ce que nous avons fait en promettant
qu'il rase gratis
s'il arrive au pouvoir alors là ils vont
entraîner des désillusions et des
déceptions dont le corps social ne se
remettra pas si on devait les écouter
bernard kouchner a repris son bâton de
pèlerin le ministre de la santé de
l'action humanitaire est reparti pour
sarajevo il va tenter de faciliter la
distribution de l'aide alimentaire en
bosnie une tâche difficile
on a le sentiment que les différentes
factions serbes et bosniaques bloc
volontairement les convois et prennent
en quelque sorte en otage la population
florence mavic partie la nuit dernière
de belgrade
ce convoi du hcr le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés n'aura pas été bien loin
les dix camions veulent ravitailler
lanclas de serre ce cas dans la région
de se voir nick à l'est de la bosnie des
villages affamés sont isolés du reste du
monde par les serbes
ces derniers ont arrêté le convoi
indiquant qu'on ne les avait pas
prévenus à l'avancé et que la région
n'était pas sûr à cause des combats
le convoi escorté par des casques bleus
s'est replié dans la ville de loos mika
en serbie une nouvelle tentative est
prévue demain
le porte parole du hcr roos et mariam
deluce et a expliqué que les serbes
avaient été mises au courant
il a même rencontré aujourd'hui leur
leader radovan karadzic
celui ci a déclaré qu'il allait de
l'intérêt serbe de laisser passer les
convois à condition que les combats
s'arrêtent au passage des camions
apparemment ces paroles n'atteignent
guerre les combattants sur le terrain
l'arrêt du convoi humanitaire ne rend
pas non plus espoir aux habitants de
sarajevo ou non plus ne sont pas
ravitaillé en effet le conseil municipal
bosniaque exige que les populations de
l'est de la bosnie sois secouru avant de
reprendre la distribution
chaque camp s'applique avec un soin
maniaque à faire du problème bosniaque
un noeud inextricable la france essaie
de démêler un fils bernard kouchner
tente de fléchir le président bosniaque
ejup h dans les salons lambrissés de la
présidence
dehors les étals du marché sont vides
ce matin il fallait être sacrément
optimiste pour espérer remplir son
panier
alors que l'aide est entreposé près
d'aéroports les frigos reste
désespérément vide élection
présidentielle aujourd'hui en lituanie
dans cette république balte de l'ex
union soviétique
c'est la première fois depuis son retour
à l'indépendance qu'un tel scrutin est
organisé la démocratie s'installe donc
dans ce nouvel état et à qui pourrait
profiter à l'ancien chef du parti
communiste lituanien algirdas brazauskas
il est favori mais on ne connaîtra le
résultat que demain matin
l'esprit de commenee souffle toujours
sur téhéran son successeur l'ayatollah
khamenei demande à la grande bretagne de
lui livrer salman rushdie l'iran ne
pardonne donc toujours pas l'écrivain
d'avoir publié les versets sataniques et
veut toujours l'exécuter véronique
taveau la flèche avance vers sa cible et
la frappera tôt ou tard propos sont
vomis 8 est prononcé par le chef
spirituel de l'iran l'ayatollah ali
khamenei
quatre ans jour pour jour après la fatwa
prononcée par l'ayatollah khomeiny
contre salman rushdie condamnant à mort
l'auteur des versets sataniques la
position de l'iran n'a pas changé la
fatwa et qu'irréversible et ne peut
faire l'objet de négociations dit on à
téhéran homme traqué vivons sous la
protection permanente des services
secrets britanniques
salman rushdie n'en a pas moins décidé
depuis quelques temps de multiplier ses
apparitions publiques malgré les risques
il y a quelques jours
ces inquiétudes sapeurs le bénin demande
à la communauté internationale devient
vouloir l'aider le nombre de réfugiés
togolais ne cesse en effet d'augmenter
dans ce petit pays des réfugiés apeurés
par la répression que le président
togolais eyadema exerce sur ses
concitoyens reportage au togo d'eric
monnier dans le restaurant il faut
chercher longtemps pour trouver les
togolais au travail aujourd'hui à lomé
et si ces pêcheurs bravent les consignes
de grève générale lancé par l'opposition
voilà déjà treize semaines
ce n'est pas de gaieté de coeur mais il
faut bien nourrir les grévistes ceux qui
n'ont trouvé que ce moyen pour s'opposer
au général il ya des mains ne veut pas
démissionner ab seuls les vendeurs à la
sauvette n'ont pas plié leurs étalages
la pénurie mais aussi la peur des
représailles à vider ce quartier l'un
des plus favorables à l'opposition
jean-benoît comme beaucoup d'autres a
mis toute sa famille à l'abri au ghana
voisin lui continue la grève aussi
longtemps qu'il le pourra
c'est une fois sans fouille ils pourront
m'aider et ce à quelques stations
essence ont été réquisitionnés par les
militaires mais la plupart elle aussi
reste fermée six voitures et cyclo
continue à rouler c'est grâce au
carburant acheté au nigeria en
contrebande
grève aussi chez les éboueurs lomé se
transforme peu à peu en une gigantesque
décharge publique à la gare seuls 20%
des trains assurent un service minimum
là encore ce sont des familles qui s'en
vont qui monte vers le nord retour nos
villes at il fui la capitale paralysée
par la grève
lassé d'avoir peur
trois enfants sauvés par un enfant à
voiron dans l'isère sophie 4 en francs
soit 18 mois et béatrice oui moi
risquait de périr dans un appartement en
feu sabrina à 12 ans y trouvait aussi
mais elle a eu un bon réflexe christophe
portera lorsqu'elle aura quitté son lit
d'hôpital sabrina pour alors raconté à
ses camarades de classe au cours d'une
leçon de courage dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi un convecteur
électrique provoque un incendie au
deuxième étage de cet immeuble de voiron
pour sauver trois enfants âgés de 8 mois
18 mois et 4 ans sabrina les jette sur
un matelas installé dans la rue par des
voisins avant de sauter et sur uk just
chrome os qu'ils auraient fait ça et
j'ai tout fait alors on fait sauter puis
j'ai dit souhaiter trio et les parents
pendant ce temps là ils étaient où des
discours et moi je t'écris 3 gameiro
tout seul ouch projet l école aux mains
et aux fesses
sabrina devra rester plusieurs jours à
l'hôpital de voiron cherche neige
désespérément leblanc n'apparaît en
effet qu'au dessus de 10 800 m en haute
savoie au dessous c'est tout gris mais
les stations de sports d'hiver ne
veulent pas perdre leurs touristes pour
autant alors elle invente reportage de
renaud fessaguet et michel levasseur
cette année la montagne sourit jaune
désespérément jaune pas de neige trop de
soleil trop de douceur et pour la
première fois février risque d'être un
rendez vous manqué pour des milliers de
skieurs c'est surtout vrai en haute
savoie dans les stations de moyenne
altitude au dessous de 16 100 m comme
ici à megève
les pistes se ferment donc avec
résignation le surf devient incongru est
interdit et par amour du ski on
s'habitue à louvoyer entre des plaques
de terre sur des pentes verglacée
première réaction un peu déçu
naturellement parce que le champ de
neige est splendide mais beaucoup de
pistes sont fermées a dit sue mais il ya
quand même du soleil
ah oui et non c'est la bonne chose ça on
se repose on reste aux trois quarts
d'heure sur survie terrasse ou plutôt
une heure et demie
du coup cette monteil là commence à
penser autrement tout une révolution à
megève le ski n'est plus la seule et
unique obsession et les responsables se
décarcassent pour inventer d'autres
plaisirs parapente piscine luge d'été
patinage en attendant la préparation des
tennis et du golfe une incroyable
panoplie qui laisse penser que la
montagne l'hiver ressemble à s'y
méprendre à la montagne l'été
mais apparemment cela ne gêne pas c'est
privilégier la prime et bottes fin de
celle ci du patin ya du patin j'en ai
vraiment beaucoup d'après ski si les
dieux de la montagne sont magnanime il
devrait neiger dru dans la nuit de lundi
à mardi prochain
suffisamment en tout cas pour faire
mentir ces images et si vous avez la
charge de trouver quelques flocons et de
pouvoir enfin ce qui est écouté ses
conseils de nos champions qui ont bien
voulu clip est à la demande du ministère
de la jeunesse et des stocks
les vacances ont commencé alors on avait
pensé choper parce que moi je le fais
pour les courses alors je suppose que
vous aussi que le maire allait pas tout
de suite vous lancer sur une piste noire
parce que mais moi je le fais pas alors
vous je vous conseille pas moi je met en
forme
avec ça vous perdez et vous êtes
vraiment me plaît
quand même sortait d'un chai cette étude
après un bon repas avec vous voyez la
piste violette c'est très mauvais signe
vous êtes en plein délire qui se ferme
et fait pas les cons n'y allez pas ses
marques et que je vous conseille c'est
d'être bien sûr la vendée sni avoir bien
les bras devant et surtout ne pas être à
l'arrière sur la défensive
et avec ça
si vous voulez voir la moto de lawrence
d'arabie la voiture de rudolph valentino
ou celle de rita hayworth aller au parc
de versailles le salon rétromobile vous
permettra d admirer n'espérez pas les
acheter les prix ont c'est vrai baissé
mais elle reste évidemment inaccessibles
reportage de pascal de ses bons et
didier rancoeur la revanche des
passionnés le ouf de soulagement est
général au salon rétromobile cette année
adieu les spéculateurs et l'inflation
qu'ils provoquaient il faisait du bien
aux portefeuilles de vendeurs souvent
passionnées mais qui pourtant ne les
regrette pas tellement vous avez des
clients qui arrivait et je crois ça je
pense je pense à un beau livre est un
endroit
on n'avait même pas comment dire fait
dix-sept voitures on n'avait pas montré
comment une voiture ancienne marché
donc effectivement d'acheter ça comme un
tabou qu'on met au top en tant que ça
apporte peut-être d'argent capitale n'a
pas aidé car les spéculateurs n'avait
qu'un critère la marque ferrari aston
martin maserati
peu importe le modèle du moment qu'ils
rapporter gros exemple la ferrari 250
gto a vu son prix doubler en deux ans
jusqu'à 60 millions de francs les
voitures étaient devenus des placements
plus rentable que l'immobilier
mais comme pour l'immobilier la bulle
spéculative s'est crevé 50% de baisse et
bon nombre de petits malins s'en sont
mordu les doigts
je pense qu'à des banques qui peuvent
maintenant voir des garages parce que il
ya des gens qui ont prêté beaucoup
d'argent et l'argent n'étant parvenue
dans les caisses on a confisqué et
garder les automobiles
et puis bien sûr il ya celle qu aucune
spéculation ne touche parce qu'elles ne
sont pas à vendre
cette cadillac est unique carrossée par
guy ya en 1953 pour son idole
rita hayworth légende mécanique pour
personnages légendaires 7 isotta
fraschini commandé par rudolf valentino
il ne l'a jamais conduite il est mort
deux jours avant la livraison
lawrence d'arabie lui est métro sable ou
supérieur il s'est tué à son guidon
voici le mythe remis en état et pour la
première fois montré au public
alors bon ou mauvais placements
finalement peu importe qui dit légende
dit rêve et le rêve lui a le grand
mérite d'être à la fois inaccessible et
gratuit
le sable convient aux belges ont pris
les deux premières places de l'enduro du
touquet à nom barbare pour une course
spectaculaire à moto laurent frédéric
bollée l'enduro du touquet ce n'est pas
qu'une histoire de sable et de dunes
avant le départ c'est d'abord cette
impressionnante procession 728 moto qui
rejoignent la plage pour s'élancer
devant 300 mille spectateurs
un circuit de 16 kilomètres et demi à
parcourir durant trois heures un mélange
éprouvant entre la vitesse pure et des
difficultés techniques ou l'enlisement
menace à chaque instant le fameux
passage du goulet est là pour le prouver
en tête pendant la majorité de l'épreuve
le hollandais vandrisse abandonne dans
le dernier tour entorse à la cheville
c'est alors le belge georges jobé qui
prend le commandement
il reste 5 minutes de course pas plus et
c'est alors la faute l'accrochage la
chute
georges jobé qui perd à ce moment là
toutes ses chances malheureux jobé est
heureux germain délépine un autre belge
qui remporte finalement cette 18e
édition de la ronde du touquet à
l'arrivée jobé a le visage marqué mais
il a réussi à conserver sa deuxième
place doublé belge donc est doublé honda
premier français david hauquier 4e
ils ont gagné contre l'ecosse ils
gagneront donc contre l'irlande le 20
février prochain à dublin c'est la
conviction des sélectionneurs français
qui conserve la même équipe la faune
saint-andré c'est la cambérabéro et les
autres il s'agit vous l'avez compris du
quinze de france qui jouera évidemment
en direct sur france 2 samedi prochain
costa gavras bonsoir je suis heureux de
vous accueillir d'accueillir l'auteur de
z de l'aveu de missing mais cette fois
pour un nouveau film qui s'appelle la
petite luxe apocalypse alors un film sur
l'air du temps mais vous rajoutez un mot
sur l'air vicié
on va comprendre pourquoi après avoir
regarder cet extrait de ce film avec
arditi dussollier et bénichou alors pour
présider jeune écossais angus t encore
c'est le club s'est bien accroché bon il
va pas florent pagny alors bayonne en
bagnole un but à tout expliquer je crois
que vous vous posez là je souffre pas vu
sa protection rapprochée super efficace
en suisse en tout étaient responsables
des services de chez nous atteignant
même les flics nous applaudissaient
quand on passe quand est ce qu henri
déposer les textes très travaillés bien
sûr pour rappel le black ne plus porter
les ex opposant le nouveau dirigeant
tout le monde s'en tape
enfin jeanne il était plutôt dans
l'opposition mais plus tard en
vieillissant par snobisme sans doute il
a retourné sa veste
le faire donnant chacune des expériences
un monde d expérience cette nuit-là
tenté de se pendre tout en mettant deux
façons
normalement tout près du mans tout le
monde donc nous avons pensé qu'une
publication de son livre en français
leur donnerait peut-être
ou alors il a quel âge comme nous se
finit problème q ce sport alors on
retrouve toujours vos obsessions si
j'ose dire mais cette fois traitée avec
humour
c'est l'histoire d'un ancien de mai 68
une histoire un petit peu bizarre
rocambolesque que vous ne racontez
c'est une sorte de vaudeville c'est un
gros clin d'oeil sur notre génération
celle qui a beaucoup à espérer et puis
et puis il est passé à côté de beaucoup
de choses malheureusement alors des
anciens donc de mai-68 anciens militants
qui ont rêvé qui sont très bien
installés dans la vie mais là par hbo
stature trouve un personnage qui pensent
qu'il est suicidaire alors ils sont
pourvus d'un gorille qu'il est
suicidaire
alors ils lui disent pourquoi tout
suicide va va être perdu complètement tu
vas pas de chichis dans les jambes des
bonnes sous le métro
autant fait quelque chose du médiatique
et tout les livres seront éditées tu
deviendras un grand héros international
parce qu'il va te suicider pour
protester pour quelque chose
alors vous avez employé un mot clé par
contre évidemment la fin de l'histoire
mais à mots clés qui est le mot
médiatique parce que là au desus et
quelquefois avec férocité un système
oui c'est ça je pense que les médias
après une telle place dans notre vie
mais on ne fait pas vécu de la violence
au fait avec avec beaucoup d'humour avec
jean claude grumberg on a voulu faire
une sorte de du sarcasme de votre ville
sarcastique sur nos médias et la plage
qui prennent dans notre vie alors
jusqu'à présent il y avait un grand
repoussoir qui s'appelait le communisme
et je crois que vous l'avez traité avec
brio autrefois
aujourd'hui ce repoussoir n'existe plus
à l'oeil à la liberté à l'aise et j'ai
l'impression que les sociétés
occidentales en tout cas c'est ce que je
lis à travers votre film sont livrées à
elles mêmes il ya une sorte d'effet
miroir mais qui du coup nous montrent
nos propres leaders c'est ça parce qu'on
a plus de crise alors les positions sont
très difficiles à prendre toujours plus
facile d'avoir une crise et de se
positionner par rapport à elle alors
aujourd'hui il ya toutes les petites
crises sont pas suffisamment
spectaculaires alors certains d'entre
elles on le rend d'autant plus
spectaculaire pour que c'est pour nous
c'est tout con con
on se sente bien qu'on s'est rendu utile
parce qu'on a un besoin profond de se
rendre utile voilà alors hier le danger
c'est l étouffement l'étouffement des
libertés
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le danger c'est le
système médiatique que vous dénoncez
dans une certaine mesure je crois
beaucoup je crois que la médiatique oui
surtout l'audiovisuel y prend tellement
de place d'un autre de notre vie chacun
chez soi et un poste ou même plusieurs
passes de télévision et il est là il ya
des choses à voir en longueur de journée
je pense donc que si on clisson de la
qualité c'est au kit la qualité pour
aller vers le spectaculaire vers le
superficiel
je pense c'est quelque part c'est
dangereux ça il faut penser que toute la
société peut se laisser comme ça allait
à cette dérive moi je pense qu'il a
fondu à l'air le ce film parle un peu de
ça sur un ton comme le disait ironique
parce que vaut mieux d'en rire
justement puisque vous parlez d'humour
est ce que cette dérive là est ce que ça
tient pas plus de la farce que du drame
hier par rapport au danger que vous
dénonciez dans vos autres films oui bah
c'est pas mortelle quand même
heureusement oui mais enfin c'est quand
même que parfois ça devienne une telle
d'une telle gravité vulgarité autre que
il ya une manipulation qui se fait là
combien personnages qui essaient dé
manipuler les huit heures du soir parce
qu'il pense que ça va ça va leur servir
ça veut dire quoi à l'image de bénichou
dans votre film les maîtres les plus
puissants aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les
politiques mais les patrons de ces
empires médiatiques qui tente sans arrêt
d'étendre leur emprise mais politique
sur combien tous complètement subi aux
médias il les regarde tout ce qu'elle
touche précédemment télévision ils
regardent les les le cours d'audience et
c'est le problème permanent la vie il
n'ya pas le drame de politique
aujourd'hui c'est les médias nous voyons
phrase à chaque fois vous nous voyez en
diable c'est pas un diable non je vois
ça avec beaucoup de tendresse est passé
d'abord je viendrai suis pas ici je ne
voudrais pas chez les diables non il ya
des choses des qualités et que ses fonds
en télévision mais visuel et ça beaucoup
de plaisir et puis il ya des choses qui
vivent dans des directions qui sont un
tout petit peu
dangereuse merci costa gavras pour votre
nouveau film la petite apocalypse donc
un film sur l'air du temps vicié du siée
merci on a commencé par l'amour on
finira par l'amour il est cette fois
chanter et jouer la traviata de verdi
inspiré par alexandre dumas la dame aux
camélias première demain au châtelet
gérard delmas
nouvelle diva divine les
applaudissements la scène en décideront
jazzy des vies nous soprano d'origine
sarde champlain trail est un pur la 120e
fois mais pour la première enfance elle
a pour partenaire un ténor espagnol de
33 ans
vincente owen à un couple de voix mariés
pour le meilleur surtout l'émotion
la traviata c'est la dame aux camélias
cher à dumas qui avait publiquement
connu une certaine al francine plé si
cette demie mondaine du tout-paris
attirer les papillons de nuit comme
franz liszt avant de mourir de
tuberculose la grande faucheuse du temps
de châteaubriant j lu et relu la dame
aux camélias le personnage de dima j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi sur les ambiances
parisiennes d'atmosphère de paris à
l'époque je vais donc très envie de
connaître la ville la réalité est et
venir ma porte donc énormément
verdi avait choisi comme premier titre
amour et mort la traviata la dévoyée
c'est l'injustice l'exclusion et compris
par la maladie valls en trois actes
péché amour mort mais un amour qui dans
le drame restent très romantique et
voilà c'était la dernière note de ce
journal le temps dans quelques instants
avec laurent romejko cinéma à 20h50 avec
charlotte gainsbourg dans la petite
voleuse claude muller cinéma à 22h50
avec robert de niro et jodie foster dans
taxi driver de martin scorsese et
informations à 00h40 avec catherine
ceylac musique avec f ruggeri à 1h enfin
psychanalyse on en a besoin en ce moment
avec deux mains à 7h50
daniel sibony l'auteur du peuple psy
publié par balles ans il sera reçu par
daniel duigou bonne soirée sur france 2
admirateur bonsoir
et
une fois par mois sur france 2 le lundi
soir
état des lieux vous nous et les
responsables concernés
faisons le pari de trouver des solutions
à vos préoccupations premier pari est à
des lieues du logement oui du logement
c'est rien du tout le drame des mal
logés
le taux des crédits le manque de
logements le prix exorbitant des
appartements autant de dossiers brûlants
que nous aborderons avec l'abbé pierre
roger quilliot marie noëlle lienemann
ministre du logement et andré santini
vos questions dès maintenant aux 45 89
25 58 ou sur minitel 36 15 codes france
2 état des lieux présenté en direct par
gilles schneider lundi 21 50 sur france
après le forfait du numéro 10 vikings de
crépon ils n'étaient plus que quinze au
départ du quinté plus de cet après midi
à vincennes le prix de la marne venue de
son sud est petit fils ne se laisse pas
impressionner par les parisiens et
imprime à cette épreuve une allure fort
soutenu
à tel point qu'elle assure toujours le
commandement à l'amorcé du dernier
tournant
lawrence automne casaque verte le chaud
favori du public entame alors sa
progression après une très longue course
d'attenté malgré une légère hésitation à
mi ligne droite il ne va pas laisser
passer l'occasion qui s'offre à lui de
renouer avec la victoire lui qui tilly
souffre la deuxième place après lutte à
titlis courageuse et timo requis
complétant dans cet ordre la combinaison
gagnante du quinté plus les favoris ont
parfaitement rempli leur contrat
les rapports des différents jeux s'en
ressentent 276 francs pour le tiercé
2214 40 pour le quarté + des 80 1600
francs pour le quinté plus à l'émiss
s'est abstenu dans ce prix salam
compétition sous la selle cours
trotteurs de 5 ans aux verts mènent dans
le haut de la montée en compagnie
d'april pearl au vert est toujours aux
commandes de la course avec sa rivale
azur durancet s'est bien rapproché et
vient maintenant les talonner met au
vert repart et s'impose facilement a
pris le relais deuxième la troisième
place pour amitié
laurent abrivard est ouvert on a beau
avoir les faveurs du public
être en pleine forme avoir chaussé ses
belles bottes en vue de ce prix de
nevers une course sur tout autre au
reste à courir à granito le favori de
celle ci en ayant fait à ses dépens les
frais subissant constamment l'emprise du
peloton
dans ces conditions la victoire va
sourire un outsider vamour l'emportent
en effet devant vannes duclos visa de
valo d'hyères qui plus que va bourrer
étaient qualifiés pour remporter une
victoire le jour de la saint valentin
handicapé de 25 m par rapport à ses
adversaires ultra visiblement pas dans
son assiette n'a jamais pu suivre le
train imprimé par les deux leaders
vignerons de chenu et sahel ulliot ces
derniers ayant ou cd ou comme une
incartade humour nda et transvaal en
profite alors pour fausser compagnie à
leurs adversaires
une nouvelle d'apprenants très vite et
très nettement la mesure de son rival
mais michel lenoir son jockey devons la
soutenir jusqu'au bout pour résister à
l'extraordinaire fans course du dynamo
duhamel retour de mara scène et mardi
soir quinté plus en nocturne à
cagnes-sur-mer quartier plus retransmis
à 20h30 dans votre journal des courses
bonsoir
mais qui résistera à l'air d'amr mes
cheveux ils sont très très délicat comme
certaines de mes plantes
et j'en prend le plus grand soin alors
j'ai choisi le shampoing ultra doux des
laboratoires garnier au lait d'amande
douce ultra dow prend soin de mes
cheveux avec une infinie délicatesse
l'extrême douceur pour mes cheveux
c'est essentiel jean point ultra doux au
lait d'amande douce pour les cheveux
délicat garantie par les laboratoires
garnier
attention ça fait intolérable pour les
enfants délicieux la mâtinant du tout
ceci les écouterons ghana c'est tout et
pour ce que j'en pense que oui ce soir
un traiteur vous attend à la maison
hawn origène un traiteur 21 savoureux
plats cuisinés pour les gourmets honoré
janin tritter les parfums 29 présente
une touche de 9,9
et
le
le parfum créé par nature une tous
donateurs ça vous change le monde c'est
la semaine on peut pour tous les petits
coeurs comme vous
oui donc petit coeur je souhaite une
pinte saint valentin
si vous avez des maux de gorge isagri
contre les maux de gorge si vous avez
des maux de gorge
iliad rien contre les maux de gorge vous
avez donc nos francs entre deux
médicaments drilles et de répondre les
maux de gorge
driss classique drilles sans sucre c'est
vous qui voyez rdc rejet les images des
images imagine quand on a des journées
trop haut pour lui d'appeler sa bande au
ccf un chargé d'accueil vous réponds
quand tout est fermé en semaine jusqu'à
22 heures et même le samedi c'est tous
les jours qu'on juge st
comme essayent de france mais qu'est ce
qui fait bien mais nous le chocolat
champions
peut-être leur délicieux chocolat au
lait ou en couleur
nous sommes tout simplement parce
qu'anne hockey même le chocolat fondant
la bouche
dans la mare
excellent projet les milliers savez
c'est un travail d'équipé
si vous voulez appeler votre associé à
merci il va être avait jeté le zéro pour
sortait aujourd'hui faute d'un bon
équipement téléphonique de nombreuses
entreprises laissent trop d'appels
sourigous vivaldi pourtant avec les
standards numéris de france télécom
chacun peut être joint beaucoup plus
facilement je suis sûr qu'il va
travailler mais oui certainement
derrière votre stand avril aura passé et
si vous communiquez avec les outils
d'aujourd'hui je voulais vous remettre
dans le jour et le gardien visite
comme vous pouvez voir tout le monde
peut être joint directement alors
vivaldi c'est fini les standards numéris
renseignez vous au 05 36 05 36 non plus
vous arrivez pas choisir entre autres au
menu mais sauf bagdad
la dame ne choisit pas madame tout comme
moi qu'est-ce qu'on prend chéri
les menus best of c'est une frite et une
boisson autour de chrome os android le
meilleur de mcdonald's en trois menus et
pour 30 francs seulement
la voie nouvelle de l'information c'est
jean luc delarue de 7 heures à 9 heures
je serai avec les meilleurs analystes et
journalistes pour essayer de vous donner
la meilleure information
qui me reprendre
la pêche est
justice entend parfois les cris d'une
femme assassinée si un général est
coupable il faudra qu'il soit pendu
ils sont trois généraux de litière et
l'un d'eux se mue en phonétique tueur de
prostituées qui va pouvoir arrêter ce
meurtrier sadique
personne n'en sortira vivant
vous approuvez un meurtre celui là sans
restriction le sombre suspense
d'anatolie de battre lundi 20h45 la nuit
des généraux omar sharif et peter
o'toole sur france 3
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir si
vous vous inquiétez parce que l'éguille
de votre baromètre est complètement
bloqué depuis environ trois semaines
rassurez vous c'est complètement normal
d'anticyclone campe sur ses positions
il ne bouge pas d'un pouce et devrait se
maintenir tout au long de la semaine à
venir
tout juste un léger affaissement en
début de semaine qui devrait permettre
l'entrée d'un front qui devrait donner
quelques pluies et de trois flocons de
neige
rien de bien conséquent malheureusement
regardez ce que ça donne vue du
satellite tout d'abord avec l'image sur
l'ensemble de l'europe l'anticyclone et
et bien centré au milieu du continent
toujours aussi puissant 1035
hectopascals à peu près ils bloquent
l'entrée de ces perturbations qui arrive
par l'atlantique toujours des nuages bas
plaquée au sol ce front va toutefois
entrer un petit peu en donnant des plus
faibles on se rapproche de la france et
on constate qu'aujourd'hui les nuages
bas sont restés assez nombreux notamment
sur les régions proches des frontières
du nord-est toutefois vous voyez sur le
bassin parisien sur les régions centre
toute la grisaille s'est dissipée dès la
mi journée le soleil l'a emporté sur
pratiquement l'ensemble du pays encore
débrouillards aujourd'hui qui ont
persisté dans la vallée de la saône pour
demain matin au lever du jour les
brouillards seront une fois de plus
assez nombreux à la mi-journée et bien
nous retrouverons tous ces nuages bas
sur les régions situées au nord de la
loire avec en plus l'entrée de ce front
qui vend très simplement par le nord
ouest avec quelques bruines sur la
bretagne la normandie ainsi que le nord
et la picardie du soleil en altitude au
delà de 800 m et puis sur toute la
moitié sud ce sera du grand soleil
encore des brouillards de sur la
bourgogne dans la vallée de la saône
et puis un mistral et une tramontane qui
devrait se lever demain les températures
prévues au lever du jour sur la moitié
nord elles s'échelonneront de -2° à
nancy à 4 degrés à brest et sur la
moitié sud
2 - 2 dans l'isère moins un million
ainsi qu'à clermont ferrand le maximum
est prévue sur biarritz avec 7 degrés
l'après midi voici les valeurs qui
seront affichés sur le thermomètre de 1
à 10 degrés sur la moitié nord et sur la
moitié sud le mercure indiquera de 4 à
15 degrés à biarritz nice ainsi que
bastia et ajaccio pour l'ensemble de la
semaine à venir
lundi je n'y reviens pas pour mardi une
aggravation nuageuse se produira par le
nord avec des plus faibles et quelques
flocons neige vraiment quelques flocons
de neige sur les vosges et le jura à
partir de 800 m sur l'extrême sud c'est
le soleil qui l'emportera toujours du
mistral et de la tramontane des
températures stables mercredi le champ
de pression va baisser le ciel sera
couvert avec des plus faibles et
quelques flocons de neige sur les alpes
à partir de 12 100 m sur les pyrénées
quinze 100 m et sur les vosges
à partir de 800 mètres les températures
seront en baisse jeudi retour de ces
fameuses conditions anticycloniques avec
de la grisaille au nord est du soleil au
sud vous connaissez le refrain des
températures qui seront en baisse
et puis vendredi un ciel qui sera très
nuageux sur un grand quart nord ouest
partout ailleurs ce sera du soleil avec
des températures en hausse
le clin d'oeil de la météo nous sommes
le 14 février le jour de la saint
valentin et c'est un clin d'oeil qui
s'adresse à la plupart d'entre vous
c'est à dire à tous les amoureux et j'ai
le plaisir de vous présenter à un cadeau
à un clin d'oeil offert par la
patrouille de france sa patrouille de
france vous la découvrirez avec son
leader le commandant conan je rappelle
que la patrouille de france et une unité
de l'armée de l'air qui est basée à
salon de provence et pour la
saint-valentin bien ils ont dessiné un
grand coeur dans le ciel le plus grand
coeur du monde
vous voyez il est en train de se
constituer sous vos yeux sans oublier la
petite flèche qui va traverser ce coeur
voilà c'est le cadeau de la
saint-valentin de la part de la
patrouille de france la patrouille de
france qui présentera sa nouvelle
exhibition le 21 avril à
salon-de-provence et cette année le
parrain ce sera le prince albert de
monaco
merci à eux pour cette très belle image
on termine avec le club le laisser me
reid demain nous serons lundi 15 février
vous fêterez les claude le soleil va se
lever à 8h01 et j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver mais 18h55 demain dans
télématin aux côtés de william leymergie
très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous au
revoir à demain
darty le contrat de confiance et rfm
présente
osez joséphine l'album de machault
l'amour
cinq nominations aux victoires de la
musique
partent en fumée
le soleil qui désigneront
posez machault
et monsieur avec l'échec que vous avez
des nids sur 36 15 crésus et peut-être
mieux à faire 30-15 vue pour se sentir
bien
un chat doit être propre c'est pourquoi
les chats préfèrent la litière 4 sam
chaque grain de quatre fans absorbe le
liquide comme une éponge et retient les
odeurs garantissant ainsi une hygiène
unique pour absorber les honneurs avant
leur apparition
cat fans je cherche d'où viennent son
goût si eunic la semaine derrière tout
ça colore déclic
il fallait lire que nous allons vers
souhaite ce qu'il en bio gallois
signifie à peu de choses près tatin pims
son secret dans un camp franc dans la
clé de fond d'un puits
france culture le monde appartient à
ceux qui l'écoutent
il n'est pas d'arriver sur terre par
accident
comment tu t'appelles petit rappel darin
les cas petit garçon de chair par qui
est il vraiment carvalho s'est pas rom
ou vous prête à détruire ce prototype
avant d'arriver un génie expérimental
tente d'échapper à ceux qui ont
programmé car les outils toute façon tu
ne pars pas darryl un conte magique de
science-fiction mardi 20h50 sur france 2
bonsoir trois mots pour décliner
l'actualité de cette journée juteux
rejeté héroïque contrat en effet juteux
pour la france qui vont en 436 chars de
combat aux émirats arabes unis au togo
le président eyadema rejeté par ses
compatriotes qui ont choisi de résister
ou de s'exiler
et puis un drame qui finit bien grâce au
geste héroïque de sabrina une
adolescente de 12 ans qui a sauvé trois
enfants d'un appartement en flammes
après de longues négociations la france
est assurée de vendre aux emirats 436
chars de combat un succès commercial et
technologique
face à la forte concurrence américaines
et britanniques
nicolas winckler pierre joxe a
aujourd'hui d'excellentes raisons pour
sourire c'est un contrat en or qu'il a
décrochée à abou dhabi où se tenait ce
week end le plus important salon
d'armement au moyen-orient la partie
était pourtant loin d'être gagnée il ya
quelques semaines la france devait en
effet faire face à deux importants
concurrents
les anglais et les américains ce matin
le ministre de la défense des émirats
tranché enfin les émirats arabes unis
ont décidé de se porter acquéreur pour
leurs forces armées de 436 chars leclerc
fabriqués en france par le giat 436
chars leclerc cela représente pas moins
de trois milliards et demi de dollars
près de 20 milliards de nos francs
un succès donc pour les constructeurs
français de giat industries une nouvelle
qui rassure les employés des usines de
tarbes et de roanne
le char le père que vous voyez ici c'est
un monstre de 53 tonnes capable de
rouler à plus de 70 km
bourré d'électronique il peut tirer en
marche de jour comme de nuit
son canon de 120 mm peut viser et
atteindre avec une extrême précision si
cible en une seule minute
c'est donc une arme de guerre
redoutablement meurtrière que les
français s'apprêtent à livrer dès la fin
de l'année 1994
et puisque les bons comptes font les
bons amis les émirats ont exigé de la
france qu'elle réinvestit 60% du montant
du contrat
dans des projets de développement
économique un sacrifice très librement
consentis par la france qui espère bien
supplanter ainsi définitivement ses
concurrents anglaisé américain de
dominique voynet porte parole des verts
qui regrette que moi de deux ans après
la fin de la guerre du golfe les
affirmations d'alors qui prévoyait de
moraliser les exportations d'armes vers
l'étranger notamment vers des pays qui
ne respectent pas les plus élémentaires
droits de l'homme se trouve une fois de
plus bafoués de retour des émirats
pierre joxe le ministre de la défense
arrêtera en somalie de mât pour rendre
visite aux militaires français de
l'opération rendre l'espoir vers la
couche tard de nouveau sur le terrain à
sarajevo et s'est entretenu aujourd'hui
avec le président bosniaque
le but principal de sa visite échanger
des prisonniers bosniaques contre des
prisonniers serbes et rendre de nouveau
possibles la distribution de l'aide
alimentaire dans toute la bosnie
florence mavic partie la nuit dernière
de belgrade
ce convoi du hcr le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés n'aura pas été bien loin
les dix camions veulent ravitailler
lanclas de serre ce cas dans la région
de pornic à l'est de la bosnie des
villages affamés sont isolés du reste du
monde par les serbes
ces derniers ont arrêté le convoi
indiquant qu'on ne les avait pas
prévenus à l'avancé et que la région
n'était pas sûr à cause des combats
le convoi escorté par des casques bleus
s'est replié dans la ville de loos mika
en serbie une nouvelle tentative est
prévue demain
le porte parole du hcr roos et mariam
deluce et a expliqué que les serbes
avaient été mises au courant
il a même rencontré aujourd'hui leur
leader radovan karadzic
celui ci a déclaré qu'il allait de
l'intérêt serbe de laisser passer les
convois à condition que les combats
s'arrêtent au passage des camions
apparemment ces paroles n'atteignent
guerre les combattants sur le terrain
l'arrêt du convoi humanitaire ne rend
pas non plus espoir aux habitants de
sarajevo ou non plus ne sont pas
ravitaillé en effet le conseil municipal
bosniaque exige que les populations de
l'est de la bosnie sois secouru avant de
reprendre la distribution
chaque camp s'applique avec un soin
maniaque à faire du problème bosniaque
un noeud inextricable la france essaie
de démêler un fils bernard kouchner
tente de fléchir le président bosniaque
itv kovic dans les salons lambrissés de
la présidence
dehors les étals du marché sont vides
ce matin il fallait être sacrément
optimiste pour espérer remplir son
panier
alors que l'aide est entreposé près
d'aéroports les frigos reste
désespérément vide
la maison aliens a tué un jeune arabe
lors d'affrontements avec des lycéens en
cisjordanie dans la bande de gaza 10
autres palestiniens ont été blessés par
balles la situation des 400 palestiniens
expulsés par israël est toujours dans
l'impasse
en revanche un palestinien a banni par
israël en 1970 a enfin d'avoir
l'autorisation de rentrer chez lui louis
15 au 23 ans presque la moitié de sa vie
c'est ce que ce palestinien a dû
attendre avant de pouvoir revenir chez
lui parmi les siens en cisjordanie
occupée
majed dakar est soupçonné d'appartenir
au fatah le principal courant de l'ol
paie fut l'un des premiers palestiniens
expulsés par israël pour revenir de
jordanie ce proscrit aura dû batailler
plus de sept ans devant les tribunaux
militaires et attendre de voir israël a
beau lire les textes de loi assimilant
l'ol paie un groupe terroriste
ironie de l'histoire le jour même de son
retour
les tractations reprenait de plus belle
aux nations unies pour les quelques 400
palestiniens du hamas
banny le 17 décembre dernier
les togolais continuent de fuir leur
pays par dizaines de milliers ils se
réfugient dans les pays voisins le bénin
et le ghana
le président du bénin lance un appel à
l'aide internationale
à lomé la capitale togolaise la
population résiste comme elle peut au
régime du président eyadema est allé
gagner il faut chercher longtemps pour
trouver les togolais au travail
aujourd'hui à lomé
et si ces pêcheurs bravent les consignes
de grève générale lancé par l'opposition
voilà déjà treize semaines
ce n'est pas de gaieté de coeur mais il
faut bien nourrir les grévistes ceux qui
n'ont trouvé que ce moyen pour s'opposer
au général eyadéma ne veut pas
démissionner ab seuls les vendeurs à la
sauvette n'ont pas plié leurs étalages
la pénurie mais aussi la peur des
représailles à vider ce quartier l'un
des plus favorables à l'opposition
jean-benoît comme beaucoup d'autres a
mis toute sa famille à l'abri au ghana
voisin lui continue la grève aussi
longtemps qu'il le pourra ces petits
poissons fruits au courant mais des
quelques stations essence ont été
réquisitionnés par les militaires mais
la plupart elle aussi reste fermée six
voitures et cyclo continue à rouler
c'est grâce au carburant acheté au
nigeria en contrebas
grève aussi chez les éboueurs lomé se
transforme peu à peu en une gigantesque
décharge publique à la gare seuls 20%
des trains assurent un service minimum
là encore ce sont des familles qui sans
vent qui monte vers le nord retour nos
villes at il fui la capitale paralysée
par la grève
lassé d'avoir peur oui si vous voulez
aider le togo vous pouvez contacter sa
tête est cette association pardon de
togolais vivant en france tous pour le
togo c'est le nom de l'association
cattrall et antonin artaud 93 1420
villepinte
et puis le numéro aussi du ccp va
s'inscrire il s'agit du numéro 1000 5962
25b à paris l'iran confirme la fatwa
prononcée il ya quatre ans contre salman
rushdie l'auteur des versets sataniques
accusée de blasphème par l'ayatollah
khomeiny
l'écrivain vit comme un homme traqué en
angleterre sous permanente surveillance
policière les autorités iraniennes
appelle les bouches à nourrir tannique a
livré jeudi aux musulmans pour qu'ils
soient punis
le temps dit il effacera rien pour
terminer avec l'étranger massacre de la
saint-valentin cela s'est passé à new
york six personnes ont été retrouvées
mortes dans un appartement dans le
quartier du bronx
il s'agit d'yves panique retrouvé face
contre terre avec des balles dans la
tête
on ne sait rien de plus pour le moment
en politique
à noter deux déclarations des
déclarations du week-end la première
viande qui avait rigaud voix à 9 heures
le premier ministre a accusé
l'opposition rpr udf de faire des
promesses intenables
écoutez le jeu qui nous reprochaient en
81 et 82 certaine prudence économie et
en particulier les dévaluations qui
était la conséquence de l'écart
d'inflation entre la france et
l'allemagne
on joue
sont prêts à faire bien pire que ce que
nous avons fait en promettant qu'il rase
gratis
s'il arrive au pouvoir alors là ils vont
entraîner des désillusions et des
déceptions dont le corps social ne se
remettra pas si on devait les écouter et
que l'heure de vérité sur notre chaîne
sur france 2 le centriste jacques barrot
s'est déclaré favorable à une élection
présidentielle anticipée
ce que je souhaite c'est que le
président de la république lui-même
respectant l'esprit de la constitution
se pose la question de savoir s'il doit
renoncer s'il doit re consulter les
français d'une manière ou d'une autre
en tout cas il ne peut pas ne pas
prendre acte d'une très forte volonté
nouvelle du pays
parce que c'est ça la cinquième rêve d
c'est que le président puise son pouvoir
son autorité sa légitimité du peuple et
que si ce peuple change d'avis le
président a public ne peut pas ne pas
vous aurez qu il y ait une élection
présidentielle finalement la fin du mois
de mars on se préférable pour la france
c'est sûr en bref l'actualité sociale de
cette semaine sera dominée par
l'ouverture de ma d'une première table
ronde sur les retraites réunissant le
premier ministre et les partenaires
sociaux puis mercredi par la grève dans
l'ensemble des postes de paris ça
n'arrive pas qu'à la télévision par son
courage et son sang froid une
adolescente de 12 ans sabrina a sauvé
trois enfants d'un incendie grâce à sa
présence d'esprit ils sont sains et
saufs
le récit de christophe tortora
lorsqu'elle aura quitté son lit
d'hôpital sabrina pour alors raconté à
ses camarades de classe au cours d'une
leçon de courage dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi un convecteur
électrique provoque un incendie au
deuxième étage de cet immeuble de voiron
pour sauver trois enfants âgés de 8 mois
18 mois et 4 ans sabrina les jette sur
un matelas installé dans la rue par des
voisins avant de sauter puis sur ie
qu'eidos chrome os il aurait fait ça
electro de feu alors on fait sauter puis
je suis sous tes trucs et les parents
pendant ce temps là ils étaient où
internet au secours et moi j'étais cuit
trois gamins au tout
je promets à l'épaule aux mains et aux
fesses
sabrina devra rester plusieurs jours à
l'hôpital de voiron le conseil régional
du pas de calais présidée par les verts
a décidé de ne plus nous sommes
subventionnés l'enduro du touquet en
raison des conséquences de l'épreuve
moto sur le milieu naturel et cela n'a
pas empêché la course pourtant de
prendre le départ aujourd'hui deux
belges ont pris les deux premières
places
laurent frédéric bollée l'enduro du
touquet ce n'est pas qu'une histoire de
sable et de dunes avant le départ c'est
d'abord cette impressionnante procession
728 moto qui rejoignent la plage pour
s'élancer devant 300 mille spectateurs
un circuit de 16 kilomètres et demi à
parcourir durant trois heures un mélange
éprouvant entre la vitesse pure et des
difficultés techniques ou l'enlisement
menace à chaque instant le fameux
passage du goulet est là pour le trouver
en tête pendant la majorité de l'épreuve
le hollandais vandrisse abandonne dans
le dernier tour entorse à la cheville
c'est alors le belge georges jobé qui
prend le commandement
il reste 5 minutes de course pas plus et
c'est alors la faute l'accrochage la
chute
georges jobé qui perd à ce moment là
toutes ses chances malheureux jobé est
heureux germain délépine un autre belge
qui remporte finalement cette 18e
édition de la ronde du touquet à
l'arrivée jobé a le visage marqué mais
il a réussi à conserver sa deuxième
place doublé belge donc est doublé honda
premier français david hauquier 4e pour
terminer cette sélection de livres ce
sont les petits nouveaux de l'éditeur
futuropolis tout d'abord s'est abaissée
de miss émane des dessins des factures
tout à fait superbe presque sans légende
c'est c'est donc l'édition futuropolis
et ça c'est vraiment je prends un très
très beau livre il ya très très peu de
textes médias des images tout à fait
surtout des dessins se passe est
remarquable et puis 2 bd alors l'une a
pour titre car là c'est un personnage de
femme tout à fait mystérieux toujours
habillé de cuir est les chauffeurs de
taxi les auteurs c'est jacquelot décédé
d'ailleurs depuis la parution de ce
livre est une non beaudoin et puis un
autre livre toujours aux éditions
futuropolis sans rancoeur c'est le titre
par choisi tout en noir et blanc un
univers tout à fait particulier voilà
c'était nos coups de coeur dans un
instant la météo de laurent romejko avec
de la grisaille au nord du soleil au sud
c'est ce qu'il vous dira tout à leur
suivi de musique au coeur des ruggieri
bonne fin de soirée pur premier
rendez-vous avec l'actualité dans
télématin dès 6h30
merci nous avoir suivis et à demain
où
bonne nuit à tous durant cette journée
de lundi l'anticyclone devrait accuser
une très légère baisse sur le nord ouest
et devrait laisser entrer quelques
nuages qui donneront quelques pluies
mais très très faible regardez ce que
prévoit météo-france pour le milieu de
cette journée de lundi au lever du jour
les brouillards seront une fois de plus
assez nombreux et dès la mi journée
quelques pluies affecteront la bretagne
la normandie le nord la picardie ce
seront quelques bruines très locale très
faible partout ailleurs sur la moitié
nord le ciel sera bien chargé avec
toujours du soleil en altitude à partir
de 800 m un ciel voilé dans la vallée de
la loire ainsi que sur le limousin est
toujours des brouillard persistant sur
la bourgogne dans la vallée de la saône
sur le tout le tout la moitié sud le
soleil l'emportera très largement avec
un mistral et une tramontane qui
souffleront aux alentours de 40 50
kilomètres à l'heure les températures au
lever du jour
elles s'échelonneront sur la moitié nord
2 - 2 à 4 degrés et sur la moitié sud de
-2 degrés à grenoble le maximum dès le
début de la matinée sera réservée pour
biarritz avec 7 degrés est en général
deux à 6 tout autour de la méditerranée
l'après midi voici les valeurs prévue
par météo france de 1 à 10 degrés sur la
moitié nord et sur la moitié sud
on pourra enregistrer de 4 degrés à lyon
où il y aura encore des brouillard
persistant et le maximum est prévue sur
la corse avec 15 degrés ainsi que nice
et biarritz on termine avec l'éphéméride
aujourd'hui nous sommes le lundi 15
février
nous commençons la semaine en fêtant lé
claude le soleil va se lever à 8h01 je
souhaite de passer une très belle nuit
sur france 2 à plus tard
partis le contrat de confiance
r b / g les imams les images images
imagine spears à la ciboulette
lbp
les images imagine
et
les sondes spatiales qui ont exploré
mars n'ont pas trouvé la moindre trace
de martiens en revanche elles nous ont
révélé de nouveaux mystères
ces lits de rivières desséché prouve qu
autrefois le couler en abondance à la
surface de la planète rouge d'où venait
cette eau où est elle passée
n'at-elle pas favoriser le développement
d'une vie martienne
de nouvelles expéditions plus étonnantes
se prépare qui iront chercher la clé de
ces énigmes
les nouveaux mystères de mars présenté
par françois de closets savoir plus
lundi à 22h25 sur france 2
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir quatrième et dernier hommage
rendu à la personnalité de françois
reichenbach qui vous le savez sans doute
nous a quittés il y aura quinze jours
pourquoi par ubi pourquoi pas diamant
johanna westrum pas c'est une grand
chantier membres c'est pourquoi n'at-il
pas penser que la broche était en diable
en sus aux yeux et c'est la fiancée de
clifford gillett
il n'avait aucune raison de parler d'une
broche en or sauf s'il savait qu'elle
était en 6e aux conclusions était une
discipline olympique tu serais sur la
plus haute marche
chérie on en a déjà discuté s'est
terminée fin de chantier
je ne peux pas m'empêcher penser à quel
point ça peut être dur parce qu'en
guinée d'être en prison pour un crime
qu'il n'a pas commis a blessé le penser
à quel point c'est dur pour nous marc
est un peut-être pas un détective et tué
ma femme et la mère d'une ravissante
poupée chéri ne nous laisse pas tomber
je t'aime
vous êtes la première personne qui m'a
vite est rentré au les gens du quartier
sont charmants général mais depuis que
monsieur sco ging a fait ce qu'il a fait
il faut un peu attention dire que
c'était un homme si charmant je n'arrive
toujours pas à croire qu'il ait fait une
chose pareille
oui et bien si vous non pourquoi m'avez
vous dit que vous faisiez ça déjà c'est
pour mon département
ils me disent jamais pourquoi moi j'ai
marqué excusez moi mon chéri c'est
madame evenson elle essaie de retrouver
une voiture voliez je crois en vérité il
s'agirait le plus que son département
ils lui disent jamais pourquoi et j'ai
déjà vu tu reconnais la voiture oui
c'est une mercedez 450 sl il y en avait
une de la même couleur dans la rue de
temps en temps mais plus maintenant
tu te souviens quand précisément ça fait
un bon moment elle était là la nuit du
meurtre
d'anciens c'était lui qui conduisait
j'ai jamais vu celui qui conduisait elle
était juste garella ne soit de temps en
temps
je crois que la baby sitter
on a fait mieux que moi je commence à en
avoir assez de toi tu avais promis
d'être rentré pour 5 heures je suis
navré mushi j'ai été retenu où étais-tu
passer d'abord j'ai vérifié les choses
j'ai donné à manger à la petite je lui
ai donné son badge les coucher comme si
j'étais sa malle est alors tué son père
je vois pas où est le problème
le problème c'est que j'ai pas et vous
et sherlock holmes celle qu'a ça bien
entendu c'est bien plus important que de
faire la popote tout changé à bb ce
qu'au guide ne l'a pas c'est ce que tu
dis sur tous les tons mais les flics le
procureur et ont juré raisonnablement
intelligent disent qu'il a fait alors
qu'est ce qui te rend si ma ligne
toutacoo tu sais même pas faire un
puzzle qu'est ce que ça peut faire
je suis désolé je vais nous fait quelque
chose à manger j'ai plus fin
alors si j'ai bien compris clifford
gillett été l'amant de gloria goggins et
c'est lui qui l'a tué oui c'est
exactement ça je m'excuse pour la petite
j'ai pas trouvé de baby sitter je n'en
sais rien elle est très belle
merci vous ne pourriez pas dû prêter
quelque chose un objet brillant mais
surtout pas pointu nous donnez donnez
lui sans merci
bâle madame hopkins vous savez ce que
vous êtes vous êtes une menace d'abord
vous ficher en l'air un dossier en béton
et maintenant vous venez dix familles un
respectable citoyens je vais vous rendre
un bien grand service que vous ne
méritez pas en rayon de mai mais moi ce
que je viens d'entendre mais enfin amy
preuves aux preuves la deuxième serrure
sur la porte
vous dites qu'elle ne figure pas dans
les minutes très bien je vous accorde
que c'est la preuve que vous savez lire
mais qui vous dit que dans les journaux
on n'en a pas parlé ou même à la
télévision vous avez vérifié les anciens
numéros regarder des cassettes vidéo
pareil pour le grain de beauté je vous
parie mon ensemble que gillett a bel et
bien regardez les photos personne ne
peut s'empêcher de le faire oui
réfléchissez une minute qui donc prétend
qu'il y avait une broche à parce qu ging
la police ne l'a pas trouvée vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'elle n'a jamais existé
ailleurs que dans sa tête
la voiture dans la rue avez vous la
moindre idée du nombre de mercedes qu'il
y a dans cette ville savez vous
seulement 6 il est possédé cette voiture
au moment du meurtre
les cicatrices sur les articulations de
ses mains on ne s'en fait pas uniquement
fracassant des dents
tiens mon trésor en décroissant un
tiroir en jardinant en bricolant sa
voiture tout le monde peut avoir les
mains écorchées puis mon mari en a aussi
sur les articulations et vous avez
encore toutes vos dents c'est pas un
homme c'est un singe gala je veux la
phase 1 de gloria autant que vous
probablement plus et je l'avais trouvée
retournez à votre marié laissez moi mon
affaire si vous permettez je suis encore
alice une minute rendez-la lui je lui
donne et adieu à la mine est toujours
pas arrivé
madame johnson adieu madame que vous
faut-il pour être convaincu plus que ce
que vous n'avez ici je pouvais prouver
que gillett reconnaissent et gloria sco
guînes si vous pouviez le prouver je
m'occuperai de lui c'est mon travail
je ne vais pas tuer ils peuvent raconter
ce qu'il veut
j'essaie je veux vous aider de toutes
mes forces
comment je ne sais pas trop encore
alors qu'est ce que vous venez faire ici
allons un peu de calme soyez raisonnable
qu'est ce que vous risquez
vous avez dit que votre femme avait un
bijou que vous ne l'aviez pas donner une
broche ouais
une babiole tout droit sans tindouf
trippante et 6 ans coûts a été telle en
or elle en avait l'air vous n'avez
jamais dit au procès et alors personne
n'y croyait ça changeait quoi est ce que
vous vous souvenez de quel magasin elles
provenaient d'une fille je suis
bijouterie fantaisie laquelle je sais
pas vous vous souvenez ce qu'elle
représentait un peut-être un papillon ou
un choeur oiseaux non c'est non c'était
pas un oiseau
c'était bizarre la tête de cette fichue
bestiole a été bien un oiseau mais pas
la deuxième moitié on aurait dit le
corps d'un animal est ce que je peux je
vous en prie vous pouvez me l'a dessinée
non je le reconnaîtrai si je la voyais
on avocat ma vie que vous vous démené
comme un diable pour m'aider
pourquoi parce que ce n'est pas juste
qu'ils vous en fais et je déteste la
justice
une minute j'arrive je peux vous parler
quel âge at elle elle est superbe
18 mois